thank you I so the talk is a slightly
different than what appeared on the
abstract so it's going to speak about
min plus convolution 3somes an additive
combinatory x is joint work with timothy
chan who's sitting here i am so the
previous two talks also mentioned quite
a bit about threesome and I it's going
to be slightly different and so the
whole workshop is about is going to be
about how problems how different
problems are hard because of threesome
and I'd like to take the other approach
see if we can maybe show something
algorithmic I so I'm going to take a
look at problems which I call some set
problems and threesome is threesome is
exactly such a problem and in 3some as
you see the definition this morning and
you'll see it probably several times
further in this workshop you're asking
whether you have a B you have sets a B
and C and you'd like to know if you have
an element from each such that a plus B
equals C another way of writing this an
equivalent way is asking is is the set a
plus b intersection c equal to is it an
empty set or not in other words a plus B
looking at as the Cartesian addition so
you're looking at it the weather all the
we take a look at all the you know just
the addition of all the elements of a
and B so what do we know about threesome
we know everything there was already
mentioned this morning so we know that
it's according to set the problem which
you go to you go to work and you get
accepted according to this problem if
you can solve at an n square time we
know that for integers that paranda
mainland patrasche gu actually shaved
off a log squared factor and for for
real for real values we have the result
of Garland and petty from a couple of
years ago where they shave off a log
factor and in general a lot of problems
in this workshop we're going to take a
look at what
is called threesome hardness and there
are so correct reductions from threesome
and one of the one of the types of
reductions which we use they're called
truly super sub quadratic and this means
that you really want to shave off a
polynomial factor so you want to reduct
time the reductions to be into the two-
eps and otherwise they don't have their
meaningless in a sense of polynomial
time and there is a this is probably
been mentioned is going to be mentioned
several times that there have been a
bunch of geometric reduction starting
from the time of egg Antonin Oprah Mars
in 1995 and in me hyper trash go with
his what was mentioned in the previous
talks actually sort of did use
convolution threesome to actually give
it a little bit more structure to the
reductions the previous rejected
reductions or more of a geometric flavor
so this is what we know about threesome
at least this is what is in the sense of
what this workshop birthday and I want
to take a look at a different problem
which is also a very important problem
is the main products matrix
multiplication problem you're given a
and B and you two matrices to n by n
matrices and you want to compute their
you want to compute the matrix
multiplication of these two and the
matrix multiplication is of a special
form you're you're not looking at the
regular matrix multiplication be looking
at min and pluses operations so you want
to you just replace the regular
multiplication by some and the and the
regular son by a min and the main past
matrix multiplication is an important
problem it's also known to be equivalent
to the all pair shortest reduction you
can reduce it in both ways and I and the
couple of years ago Ryan Williams showed
that you can actually solve this in n
cube divided by 2 to the order of square
root login and another problem that I'm
going to actually look at more today is
the min plus I
a convolution problem which is the
similar problem to the men plus matrix
multiplication and here we it's a
convolution problem see given vectors U
and U and V and you want to compute the
vector just like you do you would do a
regular convolution but instead of
having once again this you're just
replacing the same operations as you did
for the min plus matrix multiplication
in other words instead of your placing
the multiplication with an addition and
you're replacing the addition with a min
variant and me high but Raja showed that
you can actually reduce this zoom n plus
matrix mummification and and therefore
it's a it's an important special case
and it has been shown to have lots of
applications on on its own so why is
this why do I call this a subset problem
because you can take this problem the
min plus convolution problem and you can
actually define you can define sets for
for AF for u and V you take your set you
can take a set a you or you just define
your UI as a pair I you I and you defer
define the set B for for the vector V J
where you define it j VJ and then you
can say you can notice that the you your
YK which you're trying to compute up
here is actually minimum k z where you
you set the k and you're looking at a
minimum z where it belongs to a u plus
PV ok so the case which sums up the I
plus J and then you get a minimum on the
sea so it's also some set problem so you
have these two problems which are sort
of some set problems and what we want to
do is what we took a look at was we
looked at the math of these some set
problems and this leads us to a field in
math called additive combinatorics and
so additive common rhetoric is a
relatively young field in combinatorics
it connects that a number theory and
combinatorics and it has strong it has
relations to computer to theoretical
computer science has been used in
computational complexity to show off
of lower bounds and it's also been used
to show combinatorics of certain graph
problems but it has had we at least we
don't know of any or we don't know of
any outgrowth Mecca applications that it
has been used for and in this talk what
I want to do is one i want to show you
how you can use additive combinatorics
for some special cases of threesome and
min plus convolution which are which are
interesting special cases so i want to
show you i want to show you the result
actually with with a with the specific
problem that has been looked at but i
considered more of a toy problems so
that we can actually understand the the
result how you sedative combinatorics
it's simpler to use it in this case and
then I'll show sort of show you the
little bit more interesting case so
here's a problem that was looked at
you're given a it's called three similar
pre-processed world so you're given sets
some sets a 0 B 0 and s 0 as input which
you need to pre-process so each one is
of size order of n and you want to
pre-process them and then you get
queries afterwards and the queries are
of the form you're given a set a B and s
and these are subsets of your ground
sets a 0 B 0 and s 0 and what you're
asking is whether you're asking the
regular 3some question is a plus B plus
s is there a element from a plus an
element from b which is equal to an
element from s but you're asking this
sunnis basically on a subset of your
ground set so you can do pre-processing
work and the question is is what you can
do can you if you pre process can you
answer these queries in quicker than
what you do for regular 3-sum problem
okay so this problem was looked I looked
at by Ryan Williams and we Cubans out
and in a paper it was among other
problems and they mentioned that there
what you can do is you can actually
preprocess N in n 2 the 2 plus epsilon
pre-processing time and then ass
towards you can actually answer queries
in n squared times logo again divided by
log to the five fourths and at a time at
least this this division by log to the
fifth five fourth was a little bit
better than what you could do I with
then what was known with threesome so
what I want to show you now is how you
can actually solve this in
pre-processing in Oh tilde of N squared
time and actually answering the queries
in order of n to the power 13 / 7 okay
all right and what we're going the way
we're going to do it is we're going to
use this results from additive
combinatorics so let me present you or
the result and the result is a result by
by-election already in Gower's and this
theorem is the way I'm going to state it
is a little bit more generalized than
their its than the original formulation
and but there are several formulations
of this theorem so this is one of them
so let's say you have three sets a B and
s and their size their sets of size n
and there are subsets of 7 billion group
now if you get a subset G now this
subset G is a subset of the Cartesian
product such that the sum of elements
belongs to the third set s ok so they're
looking at this special G which is a
subset of a subset of the Cartesian
product where they were the sum the
elements some belongs to the third set s
ok
you have this set and it's quite big so
it's of size at least better to the N
squared Roberta is some parameter which
you can choose then there must exist
subsets of a and B a prime of A and a B
prime of be such a one the some the the
Cartesian the Cartesian addition of
these of a prime B Prime it's actually
not too big but on the other hand the
Cartesian product of the elements here
intersection with that G is actually
really big so to actually think of it to
understand this result the combinatorics
usually like to choose better to be a
constant we're not going to do that but
they like to choose better to be a
constant and in that sense you get that
the sum of a prime plus B prime is order
of n but the intersection would be order
at least n squared times some given some
constants so but yes we're going to
choose better to be a little bit more
interesting what they what they usually
don't do the combinatorial usually don't
do but for but in that sense there
should is quite a big gap so in other
words you're getting something which is
small in the addition in some setas but
there the number of pairs which are from
G and in this Sarah in this set is
actually an quite big that's the theorem
and I just want to point out that this
theorem is not a constructive theorem
it's there are several proofs and it's
not constructive so we actually I we did
it we made a construct we actually have
a construction to actually construct
these sets a prime B Prime and it's a
bit technical and it's in the pets in
the stock paper which lasts talk and it
takes us randomized order of N squared
time given log vectors and we do this by
using a proof by following one of the
proofs which is actually a randomized
is a randomized proof so it's a it takes
a little bit of technical work but it's
not it's not overly surprising and the
term mystic one is a little bit hard to
achieve and we achieve this I won't even
you can just take a look at the factors
here and we use rectangular matrix
multiplication and sparse a 50 solution
to actually achieve this so that's
that's a little bit more interesting so
I don't really don't wanna go into the
construction but I do it just to have to
mention of course that it's not that the
theorem itself is not constructive that
we can we do construct it and use it so
how do you use the theorem so one the
first thing that we do is we take a
theorem and will actually use it over
and over again to obtain I to sort of
peel off the elements so we really want
to what we really want to do is we take
this set of G which is the special
subset and we really want to cover gene
some sets we really want to cover it and
we do what you're naturally do in
Computer Sciences you take you use the
theorem you get an A one and A B 1 and
then you extract the elements from G and
you do it again and you do it again and
you do it again until you've covered
almost all the elements and you get this
by using this theorem over and over
again you get the properties of the
theorem so the sum of each of these set
is not going to be bigger than its the
same bound that we have from the theorem
and once you've done it over and over
and over again until you've had enough
then you're your leftover set is going
to be small so in other words before it
was at least bit on Vince occur once
you're under this then you can't use the
theorem anymore and you're stuck with a
set which is smaller than Beth of n
squared and the number of rounds that
it's going to take in order to do this
is going to be 1 over beta square
because you get every time you take over
better square divided by 10 square
elements and just keep on doing this
until your set is empty first thing we
did in the paper was we sort of tighten
this a bit and we instead of 1 over beta
squared by carefully making analysis as
we went down with the peeling off the
sets says since the sets became smaller
small you can make a kid more careful
analysis and we actually could
transform this into a 1 over beta
instead of a 1 over beta squared okay so
now let me go back to so this is the
code this is what we actually this is
the corridor we achieved and I want to
come back to the problem that we had
here so a problem was three some of the
preprocessed world so you're given these
sets a 0 B 0 and s 0 each of size order
of N and you want to pre-process them
and then you get a query and you want to
know whether a whether the three some
answers yes or no so though you just do
the following you just use what we're
going to do is we're just going to use
the theorem so you take you take the fit
you take your sets a 0 B 0 0 and s 0 and
you just apply the theorem we just
mentioned the BSG theorem the ba the
bulk shimmer to Gauss theorem and you
get an a1 b1 till an AK BK and the r
which is the leftover such that their
union covers all the pairs which have
some in s of 0 once you've done that you
get your query i'll get back to the
times in a moment you get your query and
then what'd you just do is you go you
first you take you go take a look at our
and you go over all the pair's a B and
our and you check if a plus B equals it
belongs to s and then for each of the
AIB eyes you compute you first go and
you compute a intersection AIB
intersection B I which is really easy
and then you want to compute the this
intersection a I and the B intersection
B I which has to be a subset of AI plus
bi and it's size is promised to be by
the theorem the size of AI plus bi its
size is going to be is promised to be
one of our better to the fifth of N and
and then once you do that for each of
these elements in this set you check if
it belongs to s and then you've actually
checked everything so how much time does
this take so for the initial thing the
BSG the BSG we mentioned that we could
do it in n square time and this is
exactly what we do
we just used the BSG theorem our
construction of BSG theorems being
wheeled around in my solution here and
then afterwards we go over all the pairs
an hour but the are itself is not too
big it's better of N squared so that's
easy enough you compute this this is
this just simply linear time and then
over here i'm skipping this line for a
moment because this is sort of the
tricky line but then for each one in
this set since this set is not too big
it's one of our better the fifth of n so
we can check each one that's not too
much we do have to i do mention that we
go we're looping over AI bi but the AI
bi we promise that there is only one
over bits of them so we're only going to
hit 1 over beta times 1 over bits of the
fifth and and then we've got this line
which is a little bit more tricky and i
and i claim that we could do to one of
our bits of the fifth i'll get back to
it in a moment but putting this all
together you get better of N squared
time because of this line for the query
and one of our better than six as I
mentioned one of our better times around
and each one is one of our better the
fifth and so you get one over bed ten to
the six then and if you put a trade-off
of 1 over beta equals n to the 1 7th you
sort of just get this end to the 13 7
time nothing so that's really the whole
algorithm we're using the bottle
shimmery Gauss theorem reiterating and
just carefully using it and sort of
using it as a cover so that really shows
the power of this tool of additive
combinatorics where you know using the
regular methods a ryan williams and
nikhil buns all we're using the regular
methods its harmful to achieve something
perhaps we can use algebraic techniques
which can actually do a little bit
better okay so that's I that's this
problem so I do have to mention that
this was sort of the tricky part how do
we how do we do this computation and so
we use a special of T lemma which says
that you're given two if you give an A
and B of size and and you know that this
their subset is order of N and then
you're even get them in a set a target
set which is which a plus B is a subset
of and you know what it is
and it's a size order of n then a plus B
you can actually compute an expected
order of n time or deterministic a
little bit more than that and in our
case if you go back we we knew we could
upper bound the we could upper bound
what the set was in we knew we had a
ground set T so we can actually do this
ok and I how do you do this you do this
by some kind of form of pseudo additive
hashing I really sort of don't want to
go into this very much but it sort of
follows along similar lines to what has
been mentioned this morning there's
similar stuff so that's also a little
bit more technical so let me go back to
this special cases of threesome and a
PSP which we mentioned so yeah in
there's been quite a bit of work on
special cases of 37 a PSP so one of them
is when you have small integers so there
have been results by alone galil and
margulies already from the early 90s and
by Seidel showing that if you have your
if you're looking at an all pair
shortest where all the weights are some
given constant and you can solve it with
this constant if it's an undirected
graph with a constant to some constant
factor and enter the two point three
seven threes and if its directive it you
can do it in a little bit it's a little
bit worse but you're assuming that all
your weights are within one to see
integers within one to see and if you're
if you have small integer using mint
puffs convolution and you can actually
also solve this once again with this if
the elements are all in with from 1 to C
then you can actually also solve this in
C times n log n by using an fft and also
if you're your threesome is bounded by
in a world of numbers which are up to
constant times n also integers in
constant times n and you can also solve
it in C n log n so these are easy
special cases which are known I may be
easy is the easies in quotes purposely
people working this a bit especially the
a PSP problem
but let's let me show you just some open
special cases so the following problems
small difference integer min plus
convolution so you're given two
sequences AI and bi and their
differences it's not that the values are
some constant but the differences
between mr constants so AI plus the
difference between the consecutive a is
is bounded by a constant and you want to
compute their min plus convolution or an
equivalent problem is the bounded
indogene ballad integer monotonic
convolution so you're given some to
monotone increasing sequences and
they're also bounded by this C times n
and that's an equipment problem another
equivalent problem is a problem from a
pattern matching indexing problem called
binary jumbled indexing and there you're
given a string and you want to compute
for each I the number of it's a binary
string so you want to compute the you
want to pre-process the string and then
you want to compute the minimum number
of ones or the maximum number of ones of
all strings of length specifically I and
this has been posed by this problem has
been looked at by many protein by many
people there's maybe 20 20 30 papers
that people who look at this problem and
I and all they could do was shave log
factors of this is a pre-processing in a
query time so it depends on what you do
but either either way the pre-processing
time for anything natural was the
shaving off of was the shape of log
factors but not better than that and
this is I and another equivalent problem
is the bounded integer connected
monotone threesome threesome and when
you have a 2d version so you're looking
at datsun you have a 2d problem and you
want to connect with three some problems
and your values are sort of organized in
a a 2d fashion so that this is an also
another equivalent problem I so all
these new results I want to show that
all these new results can actually boil
down and solved in a we can actually do
better than was previously known and we
can actually come up with instead of an
N squared solution n to the 1 point 8 59
or deterministic 1.86 for so I I'm going
to take a look at one of the problems
called bounded integer monitor monitor
min plus convolution so you're given a
and you give them be giving two
sequences and you want to compute this
see that's the just the regular min plus
convolution and monotonically increasing
unbounded problem was that the ape I
plus 1 minus a is greater than zero and
the BF so the differences between them
and increasing but overall they're
bounded by some constant times in and
I'm going to even simplify this further
to just make it simpler but the solution
holds just the same and i'm going to
just actually show the differences are 0
1 ok so the solution is actually it
doesn't make much of a difference
whether we use the formulation of this
formulation the solution it will show
actually solves both but it's a little
bit easier to understand to see this
problem directly if i want to view this
geometrically so i'm taking a look at
the two sequences a and B and the way
I'm hearing them is some sort of laying
out the sequence AI and this is our 01
10 their values and I and I want to view
I am viewing it in a 2d sense and this
is what I'm viewing and I want to take a
look at this subset of the problems a
plus B and when I say some said I'm
taking a look at when I think a point ai
ai and BJJ so there's some is AI plus BJ
I plus J so when we take a look this
this drawings a little bit wrong but it
should be going like this and then sort
of coming back to a point here so that's
money I apologize for that but we're
getting this sort of amorphous shape
which is the sum of any value there plus
the sum of value here let me just
explain to you why it looks like this so
this is our a plus B here we get our AI
plus bj and there is our I pose J and
the reason it looks this way is take a
look at the upper envelope it's
monotonically increasing back most one
because if you have
i + bj and I plus J then well you take a
look at the next one in line and the
difference is only going to be one
because we've seen the difference is 0-1
so you're going to have so basically
every time you move forward a column
there you've moved either by the i
coordinate or the J coordinate a
conundrum only move by 0 or 1 so it's
increasing so it has to be increasing
because as you move forward it creases
but it's either the changes either 01
the same is true for the lower envelope
and and the interiors for the
accelerator also for the same reason you
taking a point here you take a point
here both of them have when they're on
the line of k then the second one so the
second the y-value is an equal to k all
along and so as you move along if you
have this value and you take a move to
the next value the change is going to be
minus 10 or +1 and you just sort of you
start from this point you're moving back
and forth until you reach this point so
you basically the whole interior fully
sell it so that's how we view it
geometrically now our goal is to compute
C k which is the minimum of i plus j
equals k where AI plus BJ of AI plus BJ
where I plus J equals K which means that
we're looking at this line and we want
to look at this we want to look we're
looking for the minimum value which is
exactly the value here so in other words
we're looking for the upper envelope so
we're really looking for so we want to
compute when we get these two lines we
get this full value and what we really
want to compute is the upper envelope of
this some value okay so how can there so
one way of course we can just do it is
computed directly in n squared time but
I want to we want to do it better so how
can we do it in better than N squared
time so the idea would be to approximate
the upper envelope so in other words i'm
willing to sort of computer the roughly
where the upper envelope is and then
sort of check whether it really each
value whether it belongs to the upper
envelope or not and how we do this sort
of view this geometrically so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take a and B
and I'm going to partition the space
into smaller spit I'm going to round it
down in other words I'll
take this whole space and i'll just
round down a and round down be each one
into n divided bar and / our space so
each square is going to be r by r and
the way i'm going to just round it down
is simply taking each value and just
rounding it down by our okay so we get a
sort of this line and a good and this
one and we round it down so each one is
sort of rounded down now the number of
points in each of these graphs is going
to be n divided by R because it was like
it was a linear line and now since we
round down by earth can be in / our
points and instead of a point AI plus bj
in the some AI plus Gy plus J we get a
neighbor AI plus BJ / our lower bounded
i plus j / are but we do have to be a
little bit careful we might lose one in
either of the coordinates because of the
rounding but we're not too worried about
that we can live with a small rounding
error so when we take a look at the
result value when we take the first one
and we do a Cartesian some of these two
we get a rough approximation of
Cartesian some of the value of a plus B
and the upper envelope is also a
Cartesian some now what's nice about
this is that the time to computer isn't
that much anymore because we have n
divided by our points here and we have n
divided by our points here so the time
to compute the this whole thing is n
divided by R squared and that's better
because we have this / are so what we're
really looking for is we have this
approximation and now we want to look at
the values and find them here so look as
i said the competition for to compute
this rough approximation we can do to
brute force and n divided by R squared
time the and get this upper envelope
which is also an approximation it's also
order of n divided by r points but the
problem is is we might be unlucky it
might be the case that all our n squared
points ended up on the upper envelope or
in the approximation of the upper
envelope so in other words maybe they
all collapsed into this narrow thing and
they're all on the upper envelope
so so where does one go from here so we
want to make an argument on this upper
envelope well either the upper envelope
it represents there's not too much on
the upper envelope in other words it
repents few pairs some sums one from
here one from there or it has some kind
of special structure now this is exactly
the bubble shimmery Gower's theorem and
we're going to use them it's in other
words the argument I just want to make
it clear again so we have this sum and
maybe we cut off a big chunk of this red
stuff and threw it out and then we're
lucky because we threw out almost every
and then we have very little left over
here on the yellow line that we don't
have too much to compute and the other
option is everything sort of shrank and
fit into this thing or almost everything
but then there's lots of nice director
and we want to use it so we're using
this crawler which we had before which
is from the bottle shimmery Gower's
theorem and we're taking our s our s is
the upper envelope points these yellow
points and what we're going to do is
we're round we have this rounded down
value which we just denote by rounding
it down / are so in other words we're
taking the points from a and B and in
which we have a point aii we're rounding
it down and rounding down the eye as
well and the same with the BB points and
then we get these pairs these pairs are
a point from a and a point from B which
one is over here this 22 pairs and
together and then we're looking at the a
plus B and that's of interest if it's on
our upper envelope and if it's not
enough for a loan below up then then
we're lucky when we know we don't have
to check it okay so we want and this is
our s so we have a which is the original
set a rounded down be the original set
be rounded down and s is the upper
envelopes and after the rounded up
so here's the algorithm under this using
this idea so we take a and B and we
round it down to and we round both of
them down to these are by our squares
and then we compute on the rounded down
a and the rounded down B we compute
their Cartesian some and do this brute
force and take the upper envelope of the
rounded down version and then we use the
bollock shimmery Gower's theorem on
these three sets so the rounded down a
the rounded down B and the sum that we
get from the rounded down upper envelope
and we use the corollary in other words
we get a1 b1 a2 b2 a3 b3 all the way up
so that we get a cover of the pairs of
the sums in s star now what we do is we
go over all the pairs in our are so
we're going to have we have to check so
we get all these Union of covers of all
these pairs of sums so we first take a
look at our the leftover one that's the
easy one so we go over every pair an
hour which is a point from a and a point
from be now this point and we compute
their sums for all the pairs so in other
words if we take a look at its this
element from a but it really came from
is initially was rounded down it was
like a line going through it because
initially we had this line and we
rounded them down so we have this line
going through the square so really it's
an hour-by-hour point but there's only
our points of interest in the original a
and the same is true for be so we take
every single original point from each
and we brute force we actually just
check add their sum and we check whether
it's in the real upper envelope we take
it whether it's there or not and then we
go over all the parrots ai ai and bi for
the rounded down ones now AI is a
collection of these of these r by r
squares and each one since we now we
can't do what we did before because
initially we went here we went over
repair but here it's going to be cost us
too much so what we do is we take this
this value we just know who they
originally came from there's r squared
original a points and we denote a I to
be all the original points of a iced are
not the ones that are really they're not
really they're just that these deaths
that's what we call AI and we do the
same thing for bi so we define bi for bi
star okay so they come from some set of
original points we define these two
points and now since we know who a I'm
bi are so we use this sparsa 50 to
compute an AI plus bi and once we've
computed them then we get we take all
the we take a look at all the spot we
take a look at all the points in AI plus
B and then we can check them whether
they belong to us and there's will show
that there's not too many of them and
then once we've checked we've checked
all these points we've over counted for
these points by the way hey I plus bi be
might be more points than we need but
it's fine with us then we check all
these points then we've checked
everything because these are all the
sums that cover the rounded down version
so we might be over counting but it's
okay we're allowed to overcome we're
just checking too much so each point in
here we have to check whether it really
belongs to s or it doesn't so what's the
time for this so rounding down is order
of n time that's not a big deal
computing this as we said brute force is
then divided by R squared using the BSG
theorem we do it in order Oh tilde n
divided by R squared time because for
the rounded down version so we can
compute the esta versión now we go over
each of the pairs in our but you have to
know that our recording by the theorem
is bettah of N squared and betta
remember our capital n is n divided by r
so we get better times n over end of
over R squared bits of times n over R
squared but the pair for the number of
pairs in our is we said is no more than
our squared pairs so we get R squared
times better the times n divided by R
squared so it's better times n squared
and here we know that AI star plus bi
star is that most one is bounded by
one over bitte for the fifth n but which
is one over better than the fifth and /
r and then we use we go to compute AI
plus bi but as we said the number of
points for each one is that most r
squared so we have to we multiply this
by R squared and we get our school one
of our better squared fifth in which
comes out to one of our better fifth n
times r and ok so what you get here is
you get a you get n divided by R squared
and you get 1 over beta fifth n divided
by r betta of N squared putting all
these together and sticking in the
correct bitte and our and forget about
the adding recursion to our but you get
a solution which is n to the 1.86
something if you do a little bit
tightening the screws baidu adding
recursion you can even come down a
little bit further and you get this one
into the 1.8 59 which we mentioned so
that's the the result let me just
mention some you know other applications
which fit into this framework so this is
not this this has been shown in several
variants but follows directly from here
so truly so if you take integer
threesome you can if you can partition
the sets intent the 1i enter the one in
to enter the one minus Delta clusters
where each one is covered by intervals
of length n you can actually get a
better result as well and you can take
off so the histogram indexing and you
can do in front you can solve it for any
constant D which closely matches a
conditional lower bound of myself
together with hilda mirror and timothy
chan in a previous cycle paper and
finally the real question is is how far
can we actually extend these results
these algebraic results and does algebra
give us more than we know we're hoping
for and showing a lower bounds for that
we're going to be doing in the next few
days so
that's it thank you it's so so the
question is a good question it's been
around for quite a while so it's a
probably quite hard but but you can
really ask yourself is is maybe for
these applications maybe you can get
something better for the specific
applications maybe you could do a little
bit better
okay thank you